[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend man kann schon das gefühl
haben in einer zeitschleife gefangen zu
sein mit wiederkehrenden wiederholungen
die korona inzidenz überschreitet die
200 und ist damit so hoch wie nie zuvor
seit beginn der pandemie
wissenschaft und ärzteschaft warnen dass
sich die vierte corona welle gerade zu
einer tsunami wand auftürmt bei der
jetzt schon vieles gar nicht mehr
aufhaltbar ist selbst wenn jetzt starke
gegenmaßnahmen ergriffen würden die
krankenhäuser werden sich weiter füllen
zugleich läuft die epidemische notlage
demnächst aus die berliner ampel
koalitionäre legten heute abend den
entwurf für ein nachfolgendes neues
gesetz vor das sieht in erster linie die
länder in der pflicht in einigen werden
die plätze auf den intensivstationen
bereits knapp frank buchwald berichtet
so langsam wird es eng bei professor
spielt auf der korona intensivstation
kaum einer der patienten die hier in der
uniklinik dresden um ihr leben kämpfen
war geimpft ärzte und schwestern am
limit das macht dann manchmal schon
einfach sprachlos wenn sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger einfach nicht
schützen die die möglichkeiten es gibt
nicht wahrnehmen und daher verläufe
entwickeln die sind hier zu uns führen
und dann gibt es eben wirklich viele
patienten wo man sagt sie müssten ihr
nicht liegen wenn sie sich geimpft
hätten ganz so ernst wie in sachsen ist
die lage nicht überall längst aber lässt
sich eine vierte corona welle durch
deutschland und in berlin ringt die
politik um antworten appelliert fast
flehentlich an die menschen lasst durch
impfen
das hauptproblem was wir haben wenn man
auf die intensivstationen schaut ist
dass wir eben zwischen 10 und 15 prozent
mehr geimpfte in anführungszeichen
brauchen damit wir eine gesamte minute
immunität haben andere länder machen uns
das vor und man sieht was dort geht etwa
in österreich hier gilt eine rigorose
zweig regel kein lockdown das schnitzel
im gasthaus aber gibt es nur noch für
geimpfte und genießen auch sachsen hat
sich notgedrungen für diese strenge
lösung entschieden
haben viel eigenverantwortung gesetzt
und auch aus den erfahrungen der letzten
drei wellen und wir sehen dass das so
nicht funktioniert und wir sind in der
verantwortung für das land für die
krankenhäuser und deswegen bleibt nichts
anderes übrig als jetzt eine bremse rein
zu setzen abgestufte corona maßnahmen
der länder darauf setzt die künftige
ampel koalition in berlin auch wenn ende
november die epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite ausläuft sie plant kostenlose
tests für alle testpflicht in
pflegeheimen ärzte sollen über nach
impfungen informieren
eine dreijährige am arbeitsplatz gelten
kritik aus den ländern weist die
koalition zurück es gehe vor allem um
regelungen die vor gericht bestand
hätten und ich kann wirklich nur an alle
beteiligten politikerinnen und politiker
appellieren dass wir in einer
krisensituation uns nicht gegenseitig
unwahrheiten an den kopf werfen wer
behauptet unser konzept zur beendigung
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite mache die länder wehrlos der
lügt vor allem bayerns ministerpräsident
söder der sich gern als macher
inszeniert hatte die pläne der ampel
scharf kritisiert deswegen kann ich nur
appellieren weniger interviews zu geben
und hat daran zu arbeiten gerade in
diesen bundesländern das pandemie
geschehen mit den möglichkeiten die wir
den ländern an die hand gegeben haben
einzuschränken am schicksal der koma
patientin auf der intensivstation ändert
die politische debatte zwischen bund und
ländern nichts mehr sie kämpfen oft
ungeimpfte um alles um ihr leben oder
einen tod der wohl vermeidbar
während die ampel koalition ihre
verhandeln und insofern auch stark mit
sich selbst beschäftigt sind und
möglichst wenig störungen von außen
wollen etwa durch streit den großen
krone runden derweil also kürt die spd
auf eine geradezu sensationell
geräuschlose art und weise einen neuen
parteichef fast reibt man sich die augen
was waren das früher doch für schwierige
prozesse bei den sozialdemokraten
einschließlich verletzungen auf vielen
seiten zuletzt gab es sogar kandidaten
schaulauf und mitgliederentscheid und
diesmal sind sich alle offenbar einig
alle finden es prima lars klingbeil soll
es werden zusammen mit saskia esken fast
nebenbei übernimmt der bisherige
generalsekretär damit die hälfte jenes
amtes von dem einer seiner vorgänger
franz müntefering mal sagte es sei das
schönste neben dem papst klaus brodbeck
über das klingbeil halleluja der spd
der um den es an diesem morgen vor allem
gehen soll ist erst einmal nicht dabei
noch tritt das aktuelle tour auf doch
man kann durchaus ahnen was kommt das
ist ja nicht mehr ganz so überraschend
aber saß kam und ich wir haben lars
klingbeil für meine nachfolge im
parteivorsitz du der spd vorgeschlagen
der mann ganz links brachte die spd
gefühlt ganz nach oben klingen bei
organisierte den wahlkampf der olaf
scholz wurde ins kanzleramt bringt jetzt
will die spd von ihm noch mehr
es kommt wirklich darauf an dass wir
jetzt mit einer voraussichtlich
erfolgreichen abgeschlossenen bildung
einer koalition nicht an dem punkt sind
wo man in die nächsten zwei jahre gehen
kann und als partei einfach nur ernten
kann sondern es geht darum dass auch
strukturell sich die spd weiter
entwickeln noch ein stück weiter
erneuern muss dass dafür auch gut ist
wenn jemand an meiner stelle rückt der
knappe 20 jahre jünger ist
klingen bei zählt zum eher konservativen
seeheimer kreis der spd gilt als
pragmatiker das verbindet ihn mit stolz
mehr macht für die parteirechte bedeutet
das für ihn aber nicht ja alle gemeinsam
ein ziel das haben wir den letzten zwei
jahren konsequent verfolgt das ist dass
die spd stark wird und das haben wir bei
der bundestagswahl gezeigt von platz
drei auf platz eins und zu kämpfen die
grundlage zu schaffen dass olaf scholz
jetzt der nächste bundeskanzler werden
kann das hat glaube ich auch jeder
verinnerlicht wenn wir das richtig
machen dann kann das jetzt ein
sozialdemokratisches jahrzehnt seien
zuversicht auch bei der wohl auch
künftigen co vorsitzenden obwohl
innerparteilich weit links ich schätze
einlass gehen weil seine seine ruhe in
seine positive ausstrahlung seine große
freude auch daran diese partei dieser
partei zu dienen und ja auch inhaltlich
und gemeinsame und team vor allem und
dem guten austausch mit vielen
mitgliedern
eine richtung zu geben selbst die basis
viele jahre notorisch unzufrieden mit
noch beinahe jeder spd-spitze begeistert
am abend in stuttgart
ich halte das für eine sehr gute
entscheidung war so beide flügel in der
parteispitze vertreten sind und
flügelkämpfe wie man sich jetzt auch im
wahlkampf gesehen hat geschlichtet
werden konnten das ist ja auch das was
sage ich mal das erfolgsrezept dieser
wahl gewesen dass die partei x einig da
stand und das war mir sehr wichtig ich
glaube das ist super lösung für der spd
und ich freue mich darüber klingbeil
aufrücken schließt eine lücke und reist
zugleich eine neue wer folgt ihm was
folgt daraus wie einig bleibt die spd
nichts dazu heute sie halten es spannend
da ist er der neue parteichef lars
klingbeil guten abend tackling beim
schwimmen und ist ganz faszinierende man
jetzt diese ganzen porträts über sie
liest oder in ihrer partei reinhold dann
sagen immer alle der last so netter und
alle mögen sie sind so ein bisschen
everybody's darling ist das die optimale
voraussetzung für eine spd parteichef
oder kann das nicht auch irgendwann
schwierig werden also erstmal bin ich ja
noch gar nicht parteichef sondern ich
bin jetzt vorgeschlagen worden darüber
freue ich mich sehr und dann glaube ich
gibt es schlimmere sachen als dass
menschen über jemanden sagen der
sympathisch oder der kann brücken bauen
der können schon zusammenbinden glaube
ich habe ja gezeigt gerade in den
letzten monaten das sich im
zusammenspiel mit den beiden
vorsitzenden mit olaf scholz mit rolf
mützenich dass wir auch erfolgreich
bundestagswahlen gewinnen können das ist
glaube ich jetzt einer der großen
pluspunkte die ich mitbringe in den
nächsten wochen und ich möchte dass es
nicht bei diesem einmaligen sieg bleibt
brücken bauen moderieren integrieren ist
das eine aber ein spd als programmpartei
will ja auch ideengeber und antreiber
müssen sich irgendwie ein profil
zwischen fresken und auf der einen seite
und olaf scholz im kanzleramt auf der
anderen seite verschaffen also wir
freuen uns darüber dass olaf scholz
jetzt der nächste kanzler wird daran
arbeiten wir jetzt jeden tag und wer
hätte das gedacht bei der bundestagswahl
dass wir uns von platz drei auf platz
eins kämpfen aber olaf scholz wird ein
guter kanzler für dieses land und
natürlich muss die spd aber auch darüber
hinaus sichtbar sein und das geht nicht
gegen den kanzler sondern das geht in
einem miteinander
aber sind in der tat große umbrüche vor
uns wenn ich an die klimakrise denke
wenn ich an digitalisierung denke der
wandel der arbeitswelt der da sein wird
also da ist vieles was die spd
beschreiben muss wo sie ansprechpartner
auch der menschen sein muss und wo sie
sicherheit in diesem wandel geben muss
das ist der anspruch den ich mir selbst
stelle und die nicht erfüllen will als
parteivorsitzender dass die spd
antworten auf diese herausforderungen
der zukunft gibt nun es ist ja keine
selbstverständlichkeit dass ein
parteichef nicht auch zugleich
fraktionschef zum beispiel ist oder
wenigstens am kabinettstisch sitzt viele
sagen sogar ein kanzler muss eigentlich
oder eine kanzlerin parteichef sein das
ist relativ neu dass die spd das jetzt
ein bisschen macht wie früher die grünen
und doppelspitze und und trennung liegt
darin nicht auch eine gefahr dass es
dann irgendwann zu einer spaltung kommt
zwischen partei und regierung moment ist
alles noch ganz einfach aber jetzt 40
ländern in den nächsten monaten und ja
aber wir haben jetzt zwei jahre im team
spielen der mannschaftsaufstellung
gezeigt dass wir das gut zusammen können
ich habe sowohl zu saskia esken als auch
zulauf schuld sein vertrauensverhältnis
auch zur fraktion zu rolf mützenich also
wir werden das gut hinkriegen da haben
alle eine wichtige rolle und wir werden
nicht die fehler wiederholen die man 98
gesehen hat als wir ja mit gerhard
schröder ins kanzleramt eingezogen sind
und aus der parteizentrale durch oskar
lafontaine man die ganze zeit ja den
kanzler getrieben hat also da wären sie
jetzt sehen es gibt eine andere
formation es gibt ein anderes
zusammenspiel und wir alle wissen nur
gemeinsam sind wir stark aber auch
andere spd selbst also niemand weiß das
besser als sie weil sie haben schon
viele vorsitzende chef finden auch
erlebt sind trotzdem gescheitert sind
regelrecht aus dem amt gejagt worden
haben zum teil entnervt aufgegeben
andrea nahles ist gar nicht mehr in der
politik sigmar gabriel auch nicht ist
ihm da nicht ein bisschen mulmig dass es
ihnen auch so ergehen wird nein ich
freue mich darüber dass ich jetzt in
große fußstapfen treten kann das ist
eine ehrenvolle aufgabe vorsitzender der
ältesten partei europas zu sein dafür
bewerbe ich mich jetzt im dezember und
natürlich weiß ich aber auch dass man
jetzt herausforderungen anpacken muss
das programmatische wir müssen gucken
wie wir die erst- und jungwähler
zurückgewinnen können und trotz seiner
erfolgreichen bundestagswahl haben wir
das nicht geschafft da viele zu
überzeugen wir haben jetzt auch eine
situation dass in ganz europa auf die
sozialdemokratie in deutschland geguckt
wird und alle sagen ihr seid so was wie
vorbilder also diesen internationalen
gedanken von willy brandt wieder zu
stärken darauf wird es ankommen
also es ist genug zu tun da ist genug
platz für die spd spitze und das gilt
dann im zusammenspiel mit olaf scholz
und sie werden erleben dass diese
mannschaftsaufstellung das teamspiel
dass es weitergehen wird wir sprachen
gerade von herausforderung die größte
herausforderung im moment ist die korona
pandemie die welle die sich neu aufbaut
da hat man als bürgerinnen bürger moment
das gefühl man wird eigentlich gar nicht
regiert also frau merkel sagt nichts
mehr und olaf scholz schweigt auch und
die ampel möchte ist eigentlich die
ganze sache in die länder übertragen
ergreift dann noch irgend jemand von
spd-seite verantwortung oder wartet man
da jetzt muss sonst die nächsten wochen
nein wir übernehmen verantwortung das
tun wir sehr konkret in diesen stunden
die ampel parteien haben ja obwohl wir
noch gar keine regierung gebildet haben
jetzt gemeinsam ideen vorgelegt wie wir
das land auch durch diese schwierige
phase der pandemie bringen können also
das wird diese woche sehr konkret jetzt
im bundestag auf den weg gebracht dann
haben die länder klarheit dann kann
gehandelt werden aber ich will ihnen
sagen es kann auch schon jetzt gehandelt
werden die rechtlichen grundlagen sind
ja da und ich finde schade dass ich
gerade erlebe dass einige bundesländer
unions geführt sich aus einem
überparteilichen konsens verabschieden
denen wir über lange zeit in der korona
politiker hatten also da wird so getan
als ob man mit der politik nichts mehr
zu tun hat man verabschiedet sich in die
oppositionsrolle
ich war immer sehr froh darüber dass wir
es geschafft haben die parteipolitik aus
dieser schwierigen pandemie bewältigung
rauszuhalten und das ist schade dass die
union das gerade nicht schon ganz heißt
das ja nicht die union das ist das nicht
ebenso ebenso klar worauf sie anspielen
ärgert sich darüber dass es keine neuen
ministerpräsidenten runde geben soll
weil die spd länder das nicht wissen
aber parteipolitik spielt ja trotzdem
eine rolle die fdp zum beispiel sieht
noch nicht mal eine gefährdung oder
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
bestehen da die spd bei dem was die
ärzteschaft was wissenschaftler was
pflegekräfte was krankenschwestern sagen
oder bei dem was die fdp ihr künftiger
koalitionspartner in spe sagt also
erstmal ist es so dass alle drei
parteien jetzt gemeinsam was auf den weg
bringen da gibt es auch eine gemeinsame
analyse und die deutet ganz klar darauf
hin dass wir sehen dass die inzidenz
hochgehen dass gerade bei den
ungeimpften jetzt eine große gefahr da
ist dass wir sehen dass die
krankenhäuser in den intensivstationen
wieder überlastet sind und da muss jetzt
dringend gehandelt werden da geht es um
finanzielle entlastung der krankenhäuser
aber es geht auch um die frage wie kann
man das impfen steigern wie kann man
beim boostern vorankommen wie kann
wieder mehr getestet werden wie kann man
geguckt werden dass gerade sozusagen
auch in den pflegeeinrichtungen jetzt
die menschen noch einmal ganz besonders
geschützt werden für all das macht die
ampelkoalition obwohl sie noch nicht die
regierung ist macht sie jetzt gemeinsame
vorschläge und grüne und fdp übernehmen
da gemeinsam mit uns verantwortung und
das ist der richtige weg sagt der
mutmasslich künftiger spd parteichef
lars klingbeil danken für das gespräch
was hinter wir haben wir ausgezeichnete
und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf
weiter mit den nachrichten
die nato hat belarus davor gewarnt
flüchtlinge zu instrumentalisieren das
militärbündnis stehe bereit für
sicherheit zu sorgen
vor allem an der grenze von belarus zu
polen verschärft sich die situation
offenbar als reaktion auf westliche
sanktionen lässt der belarussische
machthaber lukaschenko geflüchtete an
die grenzen zur eben bringen größere
gruppen hätten mit gewalt versucht die
grenze in der nähe des ortes chur
schnitzer zu durchbrechen so der
polnische grenzschutz
deshalb wurde nun angekündigt den
übergang ab morgen früh für den verkehr
komplett zu schließen
im festgefahrenen tarifkonflikt im
öffentlichen dienst der länder ist heute
eine erste warnstreik woche der
gewerkschaften angelaufen wie hier in
lübeck legten mitarbeiter von behörden
und kliniken ihre arbeit zeitweise
nieder die gewerkschaften fordern für
die 800.000 beschäftigten fünf prozent
mehr geld mindestens aber ein plus von
150 euro monatlich
die jüdischen gemeinden in potsdam
bekommen wieder eine synagoge die
historische synagoge im stadtzentrum
hatte die ns programme von 1938 zwar
überstanden wurde 1945 aber bei einem
luftangriff zerstört einen tag vor dem
gedenken an die pogromnacht ist heute
der grundstein für die neue synagoge
gelegt worden mit dabei
ministerpräsident wollte und der
präsident des zentralrats der juden
schuster beide sprachen von einem
deutlichen zeichen für jüdisches leben
in deutschland
der bau soll bis 2024 fertiggestellt
sein
dass sexualisierte gewalt und vom dach
der kirche kein rein katholisches
problem ist weiß die evangelische kirche
schon länger doch welche dimensionen das
thema in ihren reihen hat ist bis heute
unklar kritiker sagen weil sie auch
nicht systematisch genug nachforscht
weil sie es bislang gar nicht so genau
wissen wollte betroffenen verbände sagen
dass die katholiken zumindest in der
hinsicht schon einige schritte weiter
sein bei der jahrestagung der synode der
evangelischen kirche stand das thema
heute im mittelpunkt keine glas
berichtet
es war kein leichter tag für detlef
sander und andere betroffene noch nie
hat er eine ekd synode eine so offene
aussprache über missbrauch geführt bis 1
grenzen der belastbarkeit dj sander
beklagt zehn jahre lang in einem
evangelischen heim missbraucht worden zu
sein im alter von 4 bis 14 jahren mit
seinem auftritt will er den
schmerzhaften prozess der aufarbeitung
voranbringen
keiner von ihnen würde ein mörder decken
ihn verstecken vor der strafverfolgung
schützen aber genau das bedeutet
missbrauch er ist seele mord auch in der
jüngeren geschichte der evangelischen
kirche gibt es missbrauchsfälle einer
meiner söhne ist spastisch
körperbehindert übrigens 2 facher
paralympics teilnehmer und wurde in
einem internat zu körperbehinderte über
einen zeitraum von 17 monaten
120 mal missbraucht und vergewaltigt
nancy jahns erinnert sich beim blick in
ihr fotoalbum an ihrer ausbildung in
einer behinderteneinrichtung in dieser
zeit sei sie durch einen geistlichen in
ihrer gemeinde sexuell missbraucht
worden sie ist damals 17 jahre alt ihre
anzeige habe drei jahre in einer
schublade der evangelischen landeskirche
hannover gelegen
tatsächlich
die landeskirche nach hannover gefahren
und habe gefragt so was ist denn jetzt
hier eigentlich
und habe sehr gute aussagen bekommen die
der pastor ist schon verstorben deswegen
haben wir das nicht weiter verfolgt und
ich wusste ja nun sehr gut auf grund
dessen dass ich weiterhin mit der
familie kontakt hatte dass er eben nicht
verstorben die kirchenführer musste sich
heute den vorwurf gefallen lassen
missbrauch nicht offensiv genug
aufgeklärt zu haben das soll sich nun
ändern die ekd-ratsvorsitzende erklärt
in welchem umfeld missbrauch in der
evangelischen kirche möglich war der
evangelischen kirche haben wir keinen
zölibat wir haben auch nicht die gleiche
hierarchische struktur wie in der
katholischen kirche bei uns ist
vielleicht eher die gefahr dass wir eine
kumpel kultur haben in der in der die
grenzen auch zwischen den generationen
nicht klar genug sind und die in der es
dann leichter zu grenzüberschreitungen
kommen kann und eben leider auch zu
schweren fällen sexualisierter gewalt
einziges beklagt dass der geistliche dem
sie den missbrauch vorwirft noch immer
im amt sei die ekd verweist generell auf
grenzen juristische aufklärung gerade
bei verfahren die wo es keine straf und
es gab bevor an der klarheit gebracht
hat sondern wo es lange zurückliegt kann
es in einzelfällen passieren dass leider
potenzielle täter noch weiter im dienst
sind die heute auf der ekd-synode offen
geführte diskussion und die einsetzung
von aufklärungs gremien sieht die kirche
als wichtigen schritt im kampf gegen
missbrauch für die betroffenen ein
schritt auf den sie zu lange warten muss
die weltklimakonferenz in glasgow geht
in die zweite entscheidende woche die
auftaktrede sind gehalten mit diversen
ankündigungen und begleitet von den
demonstrationen der klimaschützer jetzt
wird es konkret oder besser gesagt jetzt
sollte es konkret werden zu sagen man
werde klimaneutral ist das eine etwas
anderes ist es dafür auch einen plan
vorzulegen wie genau das umgesetzt wird
da machen sich viele staaten noch einen
schlanken fuß die europäische kommission
möchte mit gutem beispiel vorangehen
doch auch innerhalb der eu ist noch
lange nicht geklärt wie der ehrgeizige
green deal tatsächlich verwirklicht
werden soll florian hand berichtet
wenn es an etwas nicht mangels magnetit
dann einen schönen per videos die
europas vorreiterrolle im klimaschutz
feiern oder an pathetischen auftritten
wie diesen
wir müssen diese klima konferenz zu
einem erfolg machen das schulden wir
unseren kindern
das problem daran ist vielleicht weniger
einen ultra kurzstreckenflug im letzten
sommer der der kommissionspräsidentin
jetzt negativschlagzeilen beschert es
ist grundsätzlicher der green deal sehen
ihre kommissionen gab es trotz preis ist
bisher nur ein wenn auch ehrgeiziger
plan
gesetz wird er erst wenn die eu
parlament und rat der mitgliedsstaaten
beschließen die verhandlungen haben
gerade begonnen dauern sie zwei jahre so
heißt es in brüssel wäre das schnell
doch die einen wollen dass für 2035
geplante aus des verbrenner motors nach
hinten schieben die nächsten haben
zweifel an plänen zur nachhaltigen
waldwirtschaft und den vorschlag einem
co2 preis ab gebäude und verkehr zu
erheben befürwortet aktuell nur eine
minderheit am staaten zu groß die angst
vor protesten
bisher hören wir viele mitgliedstaaten
die sagen was sie absolut nicht wollen
aber noch keine alternativen vorschlägen
und das wird nicht ausreichen um das
gemeinsame ziel der emissionsreduktion
zu erreichen und dann sind da
regierungschefs die den klimaschutz mit
völlig anderen themen verquicken wie
polens ministerpräsident morawski mit
dem streit und rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien in seinem land da lasse sich
polen durch der presse sagt nur wir
jetzt geh bei seinem auftritt auf der
klimakonferenz unklar nur wer hier am
ende wen erpresst von der
kommissionspräsidentin dazu öffentlich
keine reaktion derweil wird die kritik
im parlament an ursula von der leyen
selbst immer lauter sie hat gesagt sie
macht den green die zur chefsache und
dann erwarte ich auch von ihr dass die
mitgliedstaaten in die pflicht nimmt und
sich nicht dahinter versteckt dass es
mit denen also schwierig ist anderen aus
von der leyens eigenen reihen hielt der
soziale ausgleich im klimapaket
es wird sehr viel mit mit greta geredet
aber leider nicht beispielsweise mit den
stahlarbeitern in duisburg die von
dieser politik ganz unmittelbar
betroffen sind heute auf tritt frans
timmermans im schottischen glasgow der
für klimaschutz zuständige vize chef der
eu-kommission kennt keinen zweifel
europa sei mit dem green deal im plan
und ein vorbild für die welt es ist frei
davon möchte ich die anderen großen co2
verursacher der welt überzeugen nicht
los die jahreszahl für klimaneutralität
anzugeben sondern auch für europa die
möglichen entscheidungen seien andere
schritte
benannt das hat europa sie auch zu gehen
wie überall wird das der härtere teil
der aufgabe
und jetzt nochmal weitere meldungen von
heinz wolf
nach 20 monaten kroner bedingtem ein
reisestopp dürfen touristen und
geschäftsreisende seit heute wieder in
die usa fliegen wenn sie bestimmte
corona schutz vorgaben erfüllen konkret
man wie wichtig ist die route für die
reisebranche enorm wichtig und dass es
fast noch untertrieben knapp zwei jahre
ist es her dass europäer in die
vereinigten staaten fliegen durften
reisen darf nun wieder jeder der doppelt
geimpfte und außerdem einen negativen
test vorliegen kann allein die lufthansa
verdient ein drittel ihrer umsätze mit
flügen nach amerika so wundert es nicht
dass die airline umgehend ihr angebot
deutlich erhöhte auf jetzt wieder 160
verbindungen von frankfurt und münchen
in die usa und das wöchentlich
wohlgemerkt flugzeuge in richtung
vereinigte staaten waren bereits heute
wieder fast vollständig ausgebucht für
den november rechnet flughafenbetreiber
fraport mit bis zu 400.000 passagieren
mehr auch an europas größtem flughafen
london-heathrow feierten sie heute das
comeback der verbindungen über den
großen teich ausgelassen nicht nur die
großen airlines atmen auf auch viele
deutsche unternehmen insbesondere
mittelständler sind erleichtert häufig
fehlen ihnen die strukturen vor ort wie
produktionsstätten reisen in die usa
sind daher wichtig für die kontaktpflege
aber auch für die montage von anlagen
beispielsweise die wirtschaft insgesamt
hofft also auf einen schub durch das us
geschäft einen schub den die börse
bereits am freitag erlebte heute dagegen
kaum bewegung der dax bleibt damit in
der nähe seines allzeithochs
frank bethmann vielen dank
knapp vier monate nach der
flutkatastrophe rollen wieder züge auf
einem teil der aartalbahn der abschnitt
von remagen nach ahrweiler wurde heute
mit einer feierlichen zug fahrt wieder
in betrieb genommen der regionalzüge
fahren dort ab sofort wieder im
halbstundentakt die bahn verbaute zur
instandsetzung der schwer beschädigten
strecke 12.000 tonnen kies und schotter
im dezember soll ein nächster abschnitt
flussaufwärts wieder befahrbar sein
in berlin haben 89 athletinnen und
athleten das silberne lorbeerblatt
erhalten für ihre erfolge bei den
olympischen spielen und paralympics
diesen sommer in tokio die auszeichnung
verleiht der bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier würdigte er die
leistung des deutschen teams besonders
weil die spiele wegen der pandemie unter
starken einschränkungen stattfanden
dasselbe der lorbeerblatt ist die
höchste staatliche anerkennung für
spitzenleistungen im deutschen sport
das war von uns mit der thriller-serie
florian geht es gleich weiter rund um
23.45 meldet sich dann christina von
jungen sternberg in unserem heute
schnell update das morgen auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
3ts umzingeln ein neues hoch hoch bilder
zieht morgen weiter in richtung südosten
für viele bedeutet dass entweder nebel
oder sonnenschein und die dichteren
wolken die sie hier sehen haben noch
nichts mit den wolken zu tun die wir
heute hatten die gehört noch zu dem
tiefe rudolf das bringt heute nacht noch
ein bisschen legen ins erzgebirge sonst
ist es zum teil auch klar und in
süddeutschland bildet sich wieder nebel
so gibt es ein großes nord süd gefälle
bei den temperaturen an der nordseeküste
oder auch hier in der lüneburger heide
sinken die werte auf 7 grad am alpenrand
geht es dagegen bis minus fünf grad
runter und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen meist zwischen 7 und
12 grad in süddeutschland kann es
allerdings auch mal kälter bleiben nur
fünf grad besonders dann wenn sich nebel
sei hält und der tag morgen beginnt
häufig erst damit viel nebel da sehen
sie die sonne vor allen dingen auf den
berggipfeln und in norddeutschland ist
es eher trüb nachmittags wird sich aber
auch dort hin und wieder mal kurz die
sonne zeigen können und die nebelfelder
lösen sich hier und da auch auf der
äußersten nordspitze deutschlands
richtung dänemark da kann es auch mal
ein bisschen regen geben und in den
nächsten tagen geht es mit diesem
ruhigen novemberwetter weiter mal mit
nebel mal mit sonnenschein selten mit
regen bei temperaturen von 4 bis 13 grad
besonders in norddeutschland bleibt es
ja mit aber das wird sich ändern wie sie
hier am trend für hamburg sehen können
der absturz kommt zum nächsten
wochenende
guten abend